[Music]
so you're no stranger to the award show
circuit I mean obviously you've been an
amazing work at a very young age what is
so different about this time around do
you think for you for me I think
honestly haven't just gone through it
before and so recently as well you sort
of know what to expect a little bit and
because it is so overwhelming and it's
sort of it's a roller coaster and you're
just sort of going along for the ride so
if you can keep your wits about you as
much as possible that really helps and
haven't gone through it before and just
knowing that like it's important for me
now to like have my mom with me or my
best friend come to an event or
something like that it's nice to have
your people with you and stuff to keep
you grounded yeah exactly
yes the nice thing is and this is what I
didn't know the first time around is
that like you end up just being with the
same people through the circuit so you
get to know each other and it kind of
takes that competition out of it and it
becomes more of a communal thing which
is really nice this weekend's the Golden
Globes I want to know do you plan to
wear black in solidarity I know well
several women are planning to wear black
at the work yeah I mean it's them it's
something that has obviously been
discussed and yet there's a plan in
place so what does it mean to see so
many women speaking up and and standing
up and speaking out it's incredible
every is to see em
to see women who I don't even know
personally for who I have admired
through their work over the years stand
off and become vocal when they don't
have to and they're putting themselves
out there in order to what we all learn
now in order to support anyone that's
been in that situation and in a way we
all sort of have to a certain extent and
it's been a really interesting time to
actually open up the conversation and
have it sort of almost open your eyes to
the environment and how it needs to
change and and yeah it's been really
incredible as a young person as well
even though I've worked in the industry
for a very long time to really feel part
of a community of women and a union of
women is amazing and men as well you
know I love all of the men in the
industry who are incredibly supportive
of this movement it's great it's a joint
effort it needs to come from everyone so
powerful message coming from a lot of
powerful women themselves
congratulations on everything happen
this week
you